hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
mensch heute möchte ich euch endlich
mein werkzeug vorstellen und auch meine
küche ich muss nur das zu sagen meine
küche die ständig klein bisschen der vor
kurzem umgezogen
aber es passt alles rein ich hab jetzt
noch ein paar möbel mit dazu gekauft die
küche habe ich nämlich mitgenommen dass
ich noch eine alte küche und dann würde
ich sagen starten wir einfach und ich
zeige euch mal wie es hier so bei mir
aussieht dann fangen wir am besten
gleich an diese stutter hintere teil
meiner küche
ich habe jetzt weise parallele
arbeitsflächen und hier zum beispiel
habe ich meine gläser trend dass ich
eigentlich so eine kommode von ikea war
die glaube ich und die hängt eigentlich
so rum und ich habs jetzt einfach
waagerecht offen aufgehängt und der
decke geht nach oben auch und hier habe
ich so eine folie geklebt weil es
einfach nur weiß war und das sind
einfach meine gläser trend das ist
eigentlich immer ganz praktisch und man
sieht wie viele gläser drin 10
und jeder weiß wo meine g verstehen und
hier unter der vitrine habe ich so drei
promoten die habe ich von ikea gekauft
die sie noch nicht ganz fertig ist
braucht nämlich für jede kommune noch
diesen henkel daran
oder habe ich eigentlich so dass mein
spielzeug verstaut ich weiß nicht
vielleicht mache ich mir doch eine
arbeitsplatte über oder so auf jeden
fall habe ich dann meine freude und
meinte das ist die frage in mainz was
mich dass herr minx wieso braucht
studien und wieso gehst du denn sagen ja
dazu machte man extra video also jeder
der jeden tag kocht und den thermomix
jeden tag benutzt finde ich müsste ich
denn zu legen größeren zeitersparnis und
trotzdem nicht teuer aber wirklich gut
also ich kann ein eigentümer
weiterempfehlen
ja ansonsten bis jetzt nicht mehr so
wichtig ich kann nicht von meinen bart
schouten zeigen
das ist eigentlich auch mal ganz
interessant als ich hier einfach so ein
system drin
ich habe hier zum beispiel die ist ganz
wechsel was ich immer so zu modellieren
benutzt zum ausrollen zum ausstechen
hier sind auch meine lollipops tricks
drin für die tecops darunter habe ich so
ein ornament die man zum stanzen
benutzen
mein wels ihr könnt auch hier ganz gut
sehen das sind hier meine spritzbeutel
sachen zu spritzen die habe ich immer
auf das braucht man eigentlich auch
immer ganz oft beim backen
hier habe ich blumen ausstechen hier ist
einfach nichts zubehör mit drin wie
draht und ein verstoß steine hier habe
ich auch diese unterlage die braucht man
wenn man blumen selber machen wir aus
blüten passte das werde ich euch aber
alles ganz dann im detail zeigen
ich sage euch es nämlich ein projekt und
ihr sagt dann was euch interessiert und
auf was ich näher eingehen sollen
da habe ich dieses mosa die braucht man
um von dem blatt zu streichen
und dann habe ich hier auch noch mit
back matte
von tchibo die schau für mich gut aus
silikon
die gibt's auch von tupperware unter
anderem fielmann aber die von tchibo war
ziemlich günstig ich glaube zehn euro
gekostet und hier habe ich buchstaben
ausstellte aus plastik dies sind auch
super
in meiner zweiten schublade habe ich
hier auch nur ausstecher das sind meine
weihnachts ausstecher hier habe ich
meine anderen ausstecher herzchen oster
ei und alles andere hier in dem behälter
sammle ich meine papier förmchen für
muffins und dieser behälter dabei ein
paar an acht rinder aufgeschnittene die
kammer bei uns zu kaufen und dann habe
ich einfach den behälter auf geworden
und habe ihn gewaschen und jetzt soll
ich damit meine paket vom stand drin
hier habe ich meine ein weg stoffbeutel
drin die ich mir mal in massen
angeschafft um diese nächtliche gut
würde ich auch jedem empfehlen
und hier habe ich mein werkzeug das
gleich mal im detail war hier oben
dieses ganze weg zurück wollte und
lebensmittel stifter also alles was man
eigentlich so zu müssen
braucht mein schneidewerkzeug also hier
zum beispiel eine pinzette meinen kater
scheren aus roller
das kann eigentlich alles immer ganz gut
nutzen hier zum beispiel den finde ich
ganz gut mit dem kann ich so zickzack
schneiden und kann die rädchen einfach
austauschen was ich hier noch habt es
sind so cartridges und zwar von meiner
krieg ok ich hab nämlich eine
schneidemaschine die benutze ich nur
viel zu selten das muss ich mir mal
bislang muss ich mich bisschen ein lesen
dass sich die richtig benutzen kann da
kann man diese ganzen ornamente aus
sondern oder aus blüten passte nämlich
schneiden lassen und muss dann nicht
selber hin stimmt und es schneiden hier
habe ich noch ein paar kuchenformen main
aus kühl gitter und die staaten platten
dann geht es hier weiter mit meinen also
das sind eigentlich alle die ich habe
mehr hab ich nicht da habe ich silikon
backformen da mag ich aber eigentlich
nur die muffin backformen und cupcakes
abfahren
wir sind ganz frisch die haben unter tel
da kann man dann den man findet ja dann
die große frage
wo hast du deine wack rahmen her meine
back rahmen die hole ich alle von bei
lohmar wasserfläche drauf und gut
abgetrocknet
dies sind zwar also diesen preis nicht
okay der vorteil am gemäuer backformen
ist einfach mal packt ohne boden so dass
ich quasi die springform ihr braucht nur
den bug rand und dann habt ihr hier im
ofen wenn ihr da mal ein guckt nicht an
habe ich hier so ein spender unter bares
gitter drauf da kommt eine folie drauf
und dann eben diese passform
die bankführung ist super hier fort
nämlich 200 weniger zeit deswegen auf 21
prozent weniger energie und hab das
alles eben gespart doch ganz toll ich an
denen ihr könnt ihn spülmaschine stecken
ihr könnt sie zusammendrücken wie ihr
wollt ich bringen immer in die
ausgangsposition wieder zurück also egal
wie station verbiegt da passiert absolut
nicht hier habe ich noch so ein paar
kleine förmchen da kann man eiswürfel
dann machen oder zum beispiel schokolade
schmelzen
dann habe ich hier noch das ist auch
ganz gut
meine drei platter das ist keine
besondere die habe ich einfach bei ikea
gekauft die ich auch nicht teuer ich bin
jetzt sicher auf die sieben oder acht
euro das so irgendwie kostet hier habe
ich diese torten unterlagen meine torten
behältern und das war es eigentlich
schon als und auf den rechten weg so
interessant in den anderen skifahren
habe ich einfach meinen super sachen
drin hier zum beispiel ich sortiere es
einfach immer so nach form also rund
verlosen hier habe ich so einen apfel
china und schneidert der problembank mal
aus das kann ich euch dann zeigen meine
zitronenpresse von louis
die habe ich ganz günstig bekommt ihr
nun euro gekostet bei globus
allerdings gibt es da nicht mehr und im
internet sehen wir auch schwer zu
bekommen
aber wenn ihr glück habt vielleicht mal
bei ebay oder amazon karate ihm auch gut
bekommen
dann habe ich hier noch weiter den habe
ich schon mal vorgestellt
dem wird sich immer noch sehr gerne den
echt komplett zufrieden damit und mal
gucken wo ich noch die restlichen
aufsätze bekommen
hier habe ich
restlichen sachen auch die deckel und so
weiter ihr wolltet ihr auch wissen wie
ich das ganze zeug in meiner kleinen
küche verstauen
also hier deswegen meine schränke da
noch restliche kuchen behälter große
formen zu schleudern
dann habe ich hier noch meine
kaffeemaschine die deutsche post
wir trinken kaffee von da steht die
meistens nur um und in dieser schublade
habe ich zum beispiel meine
elektrogeräte meint oster da ist so ein
donut mega ein anderer toaster ich habe
ich auch den digital oder getrieben und
immer auch so ein lehrstück habe ergibt
hier vielleicht weiter die zweite alexis
so war die habe ich mir mal in mannheim
glaub ich gekauft beinahe da habe ich
zum beispiel die kapseln drin für die
deutsche kunst da habe ich meine
zwiebeln und kartoffeln drin in der
schublade das ist so ein bisschen vorrat
und stinkt schuppler hat also mein
fahrrad wo meine tochter ebene dran
kommen sollen die reinigungsmittel
hier habe ich so ein behälter gesammelt
da die tüten drin alufolie und so weiter
und sofort meine scherze natürlich das
hier ist sonne alles in eine schublade
der data miner bretter und daneben das
ganze flaschen becher plastiklöffel die
idee sagt ihr zu viel sinn alles hier
drin
genau das ist mein fahrrad da muss ich
mir noch überlegen die möchte ich
eigentlich nett hier in dem schrank
ich muss mal gucken wo ich die rein
macht
und hier noch der rest das sind noch ein
paar gläser die ich auspacken muss ich
sag mir wo niveau notieren dann jetzt
weiter auf diese seite hier kann ich
euch noch meine flagge zeigen
vielleicht als kurs also was betrifft
jedes backen zum beispiel ist die serie
habe ich die bildet sich ein schnitzer
oft also wenn ich was an recht richtig
auch so anwohnerin sonntags portionierer
kann man immer ganz gut benutzen für
funktionale ausdrücken kann man ganz gut
für keks benutzen
du weißt ja auch mittlerweile dieser
cache meter gibt also ich war zwar lange
dagegen aber ich glaube ich hole mir
auch nur einmal dieses zu rollen die
ganze zeit ist echt des so zeitraubend
hier habe ich noch ein paar zeigt haben
die finde ich immer gut sagt man
eigentlich immer haben
hier habe ich ganz vergessen euch noch
meine folien zu zeigen
das sind die folien von blumen bei dem
muss man nur aufpassen auf denen darf
man nicht schneiden sonst gehen sie
kaputt
das ist mir auch ein paar schon kaputt
gegangen die stelle ich euch aber
irgendwann anders noch mal richtig vor
und hier habe ich meinen stil sammler da
habe ich meine grenzen aber drin vom
thermomix meinte kinzel desch auch von
nomura
ich finde dieses silikon pinsel einfach
spitze weil sie einfach nicht haaren
entsteht sind ja auch ziemlich
hitzebeständig ja und kochlöffel und so
weiter hier ist meine kleine vorrat
schublade
da habe ich immer so backpulver meine
farben pulver fahren
hier habe ich meine fastenphase als ihr
seht ich habe jetzt nicht so viel und
kommt mit den farben eigentlich ganz gut
aus die kauft nicht bei dekoration oder
so das ist ein shop in holland und da
das sind einfach die günstigsten also
weder ebay lösung kommt an den
preisrahmen deswegen beständig da immer
ganz gern uns halt ja das steht hat als
auch niederländisch auf der steuer auf
der seite und hier habe ich dann eben
einfach noch einen schubser dieses ganze
dekor zeug schokolade scheller tine und
alles mögliche
da habe ich noch ein paar elektrogeräte
ja vieles sei jetzt für mich übrig weil
ich jetzt den thermomix hat aber der
stabmixer zum beispiel hat den kann man
immer gebrauchen das hier ist dieser
mister magic mensch eigentlich auch
nicht schlecht aber einfach zu klein
und natürlich meinen stinknormales hans
böck gerät
hier oben habe ich einfach unsere tassen
drin
unterwegs noch der darauf saß der roma
in dem kann man ganz gut gemüse fleisch
und reis diensten den benutze ich
eigentlich ziemlich häufig weil das so
fettaugen kochen kann und einfach alles
seinen eigenen geschmack beherrscht hier
habe ich meine küchenmaschine drin
ich werde schauen also die ich
eigentlich ganz gut die habe ich von
lidl bekommen meine schwester hat sie
mir geschenkt und ich bin eigentlich
recht zufrieden damit aber ich möchte
mir irgendwann dann mal eine kitchenette
vorlegen
man hoffe irgendwann halt da habe ich
meinen restlichen vorm arzt drin
ich habe irgendwann ganz ganz günstig
diese tupperdosen geprägt ist nämlich
ziemlich teuer und für das geld hätte
ich mir niemals gekauft habe alle
tupperdosen ich glaube 25 euro gekriegt
also pro dose nicht mal ein euro gezahlt
das war echt ein wunder und da oben habe
ich nochmal so verrät hier habe ich
immer schokolade drin und nüsse und oben
drin hab ich so gewürze und alles war es
eigentlich so zum backen gebraucht wird
und jetzt noch vielleicht mein letzter
schrank ich habe hier noch einen kleinen
schrank da habe ich oben ein porzellan
drin und hier habe ich so sachen wie
kaffee tee kaffee gewürze und meine
auflaufformen und natürlich auch die
brotkörbe ja also das war es eigentlich
nur in allem mixa diese super dosen
schlecht bewertet diesen super cup mit
der beschriftung ich mag es sehr wenn
alles beschriftet ist
und die gibt es auch so vorgefertigt und
man kann sich auch ein beschriftung
gerät hole jetzt habe ich nicht deswegen
schreibe ich dann
wie gesagt mit der hand drauf was ich
noch an geräten habe ich zum beispiel
sondern so ein schwätzle spezialpresse
oder eine nudelmaschine die habe ich
aber nicht in meiner küche da hab ich
echt zu wenig platz dafür
falls ihr möchtet wie gesagt meldet euch
nochmal was ich euch noch mal genau
zeigen so jetzt habt ihr was und
überblick und ich weiter das sowieso
dann immer in meinen videos benutzen
sagte ich dann einfach immer woher ich
das halbwegs möchtet dann könnt ihr euch
das auch besorgen
ich möchte nicht zu viel werbung machen
auch wenn diese flut mache ich das
natürlich gerne
dann wünsche ich euch jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video
ich hoffe ich konnte einfach ein paar
sachen zeigen die ich halt in meiner
küche habe die man vielleicht mehr
zwingend braucht aber jeder haben sollte
und wünsche euch noch einen ein schönes
wochenende und bis zum nächsten mal